[Music]
we all know the importance of airport
security
so as you head through the checkpoint
this holiday season with food and gift
items we here at the TSA hope you'll
keep in mind this friendly gift guide to
the 12 banned items of Christmas
otherwise your friendly local TSA agent
might give you an enhanced pat-down - my
junk I'm gonna have you arrested so what
is a gel here at the TSA we've just
decided to ban most of your holiday
favorites cranberry sauce gravy dip
maple syrup but it's not that simple
take this avocado solid food absolutely
legal to carry on but then guacamole
tasty but also an officially prohibited
TSA gel you can carry on a cherry pie
but you absolutely cannot bring the
cherry filling alone
[Music]
now we're safe you cannot bring a 1 inch
pocket knife or other TSA designated
thrusting weapons except vibrators you
can however bring metal scissors with
pointy 4-inch blades or giant steel
knitting needles
please do not thrust here or here if
you're looking for a gift with an edge
just remember that you can't bring
anything with a blade like a corkscrew
you can however bring ice skates don't
worry the human skull is slightly harder
than this
sometimes sporting goods can be
dangerous for example TSA designated
sporting blood Jets like this wiffle
ball bat fortunately you can take
titanium tennis racquets we all know
that you can't bring a pool cue but you
can bring a fishing rod but what should
you get the bowlers in your life you
cannot bring a bowling pin but you can
carry on a bowling ball because only the
pin is a bludgeon you can't bring a
container containing more than 3.4
ounces of liquid then again you actually
can as long as you label it breastmilk
all better you cannot take a snow globe
that's bigger than a tennis ball you can
however take a giant globe that is
filled with water provided that it also
contains live fish
[Music]
you cannot take even a single compressed
co2 cartridge unless you have a life
vest in which case you can take four
remember that you can bring a single
lighter and/or matches and don't even
try to bring two match books or we here
at the Transportation Security
Administration would like to thank you
for following these rules even though
they've never stopped a terrorist much
like Santa Claus we only make you more
secure if you believe happy holidays
from the TSA other officially proof
carry-on items include tattoo guns 7f
screwdrivers puppies inflatable cacti
transcutaneous electrical nerve
stimulators maracas whoopee cushions
$10,000 cash folding shopping carts
artificial skelton bones for medical
school and up to five pounds of anti dry
ice your safety is our priority
you